[Music]
[Applause]
we're at the FTTH conference I'm talking
to Pascale real under the CEO of kovash
a unique company Pascale tell us why you
are unique in the fibre world Thank You
Bryan I think we are a unique company
because since the inception of the
company back in 2006 we have done only
one business which is a fibre and in not
only one business fibre but we also set
up a model which is still the same model
which is a we are only a wholesale fiber
infrastructure operator we don't have
any retail branch so we build we operate
the network and we sell this network if
I may say so or run the network to the
ISPs and that's one model and we we did
it at the beginning with fibre to the
office infrastructure because there was
a big demon for the businesses to get
access to the fibre and as you surely
know we have a big push for ftth know
together to give access to fibre to the
consumer market and that was that's what
we have been doing the during the past
couple of years also yes I mean the
markets really taking off in France
isn't it I mean at least yeah I mean you
can say that because the market is
taking off for many different reason by
the way I think that if I try to answer
to your question really properly I think
first of all there is a very strong push
for the from the governments you know
they the government really wants to give
access to high-speed bandwidth to
everybody every businesses every
consumer so there is a big political
crucial would say then after there is
also very strong consumer demands you
have to face it I mean you cannot wait
you cannot run a business today if you
don't have access to this very high
speed bandwidth because your application
are somewhere in the cloud for example
and you want to have reliable and very
high speed access to those application
and even if you are a consumer you wanna
have a very
good access to your TV to your content
to your video on-demand and so on but
there is a very very strong consumer
demand and maybe the last point which is
not the smallest one is that there is an
quite significant competition between
the ISPs so as soon as you bring you
know high quality high reliability fiber
infrastructure to the market basically
the ISPs they really want to benefit
from it and they go for it sounds like
things are going really well when a
market moves as quickly as your market
is moving there are often technical
challenges financial challenges are you
finding any of that yeah that's really
true in fact I mean when you have a such
a positive environment then that's where
the issue really starts you know the
issues really start I would say that you
know basically we have a two type of
challenges I would not say issues by the
way we said challenges the first one is
of course we have to we have to manage
the construction of the network and and
there is a lot of pressure on the on the
and the human resources being available
to build the network on the on the on
the subcontractor on the cable and and
and if you find a way to get access to
the sufficient resources on our
organization to build such a network
then after of course you have to deal
with pretty I pie season because it's
it's a German driven market and and and
the price can go up so you have to
factor if all of those factors in and
and still being able to deploy the
network in the in the you know in the
planning and at the cost level that you
that you have designed so that's one
challenge clearly the other challenge in
the past was to find the adequate
financing to do so because we are
talking about a huge capex of course
when when you build the millions of own
paths
and basically we have received a very
positive answer from first of all
shareholders there is a money available
from private equity fund for example
that are willing to invest in 2005
structure because they do understand
that this is a very robust
infrastructure and that we're going to
use it for many many many years to come
and this will generate revenue so this
was the first first level and then after
I think we have done a decent job in
terms of education of the bank and
really we know how about so access to
final things who bank loans at at good
conditions so I would say that we have
secured so far the financing toward to
build those networks fantastic well
thank you for talking to us and I hope
you continue to rise to the challenge in
France thank you Brian
[Music]
you